good morning belief nation today's
messages let fear motivate you over to
you will Smith I'm motivated by fear
fear you know fear of what fear of fear
I hate being scared to do something I
hate that feeling of the feeling that I
had before I had a meeting with Quincy
Jones because it's really Quincy Jones
and a guy named Benny Medina who I know
and Jeff Pollan came with the idea for
the Fresh Prince of bel-air and I hated
being scared you know
like that I didn't want to even take the
meeting there were there were
opportunities during when I first my
first year as a rapper Bill Cosby and
the people in The Cosby Show had seen my
music video and called me to be a
character to come right and try out for
the Cosby Show and just every time it
was set up for some reason I couldn't
make it the fear of theatre fear I hated
I just hated that being scared to do
something and I think what developed in
my in my early days was the the attitude
that I started attacking things that I
was scared this is a important message
because fear holds us all back from
doing things that we want to do and
you're never gonna get rid of the fear
but you should feel the fear and do it
anyway
and I'm gonna give you a personal
example from my my life in my business I
came across an agency and they support
and work with people who are business
experts and thought leaders and I've
never heard of an agency for experts he
heard of agencies for you know athletes
and models and celebrities but not for
business thought leaders and in order to
start working with them I had to do a
few things that I was uncomfortable with
that I'd never done before that was
stretch
my comfort zone and and I almost didn't
do it and I told myself why am I not
wanting to go forward with this is it
because there's a legitimate reason or
is it just because I'm afraid and
reality it was because I was afraid and
what helped me make the decision was I
didn't want to look back on my life and
and regret not moving forward with these
guys I had never heard of this
opportunity before and I really wanted
to do it so I went forward and and
despite the fact that I was scared I
went for it and it worked out and the
videos have gotten better and I've
gotten book deals and corporate gigs and
my business has grown because of that
decision and so you want to approach it
the same way in your business you want
to make sure that fear can be a
counselor to you but but not a jailer
don't let it hold you back from doing
something that you really want to do
because because you're afraid and so my
question is a for you today is what are
you afraid of well how does fear hold
you back in your business Reuben in your
life I'm really curious to find out
leaving a comment below on your joining
the discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of an oppressor